the men you want out there castrating
the rapists the men you cling to when
the wolves at the door they're never the
white knight modern male feminists who
travel in packs like the wolves those
men are cowards they don't respect women
they're just looking for an inn and I
saw this at the change my mind with the
guys walking in going well I think that
this made my friend cry you're just
trying to get laid man you know usually
wanted to talk about because I
definitely do think that this we always
talk about how sort of toxic politics
has become and how angry people are and
I want to bring it back to the fact
there's nothing wrong with anger there's
nothing wrong with righteous anger and I
certainly think that being falsely
labeled a rapist
would qualify but let me take a step
back when you were a kid you even look
up to your dad because he was sweet or
because he had nice clothes
your dad was worth his salt because he
felt safe if he had a good dad or even
more so I would say that it was
certainly like with my dad it's because
he made everyone around him feel safer
so this is actually something I'd like
to talk about with the dead both a
deadbeat man out there and the women who
tolerate deadbeat men first to all the
feminists who [ __ ] about toxic
masculinity and rape culture and that's
what they're shrieking about today let
me make this really simple what should
you look for in a man an honest man with
a backbone that's it you want a man who
you're going to reach for when the
wolves are at the door and to the men
we've talked about this a lot that the
in cells right the involuntary celibates
the professionally outraged over alimony
and child support payment crowd sorry
I'm not on board with you I understand
equality I understand people being upset
with feminists and how far they've
reached but this men's rights crowd that
sometimes just goes too far the other
way you know what you need to learn to
be the person that your woman's gonna
want when wolves are at the door now why
is that symbolism so important wolves at
the door you hear that a lot razor [ __ ]
what why wolves at the door a few things
one it's not meaning people at the door
meaning you're not one of them there's a
delineation it's an animal
- it's not Tigers at the door it's not
water moccasins those are really freaky
though if you see the water snakes and
they do what their head up but they
terrify me it's wolves and a big wolves
are pack animals
very seldom are they dangerous by
themselves but in a pack they become
ruthless and bold and killers and that's
why you have to protect yourself against
the pack of wolves can come in the form
of a pitch for
Mobb the trial by public opinion the
gossipers in your church the gaggle of
so-called friends who betray you when
you thought they wouldn't peer pressure
hell it could actually be a gang of
rapists the pack of wolves could be a
gang of rapists but this whole rape
witch-hunt
it's a throwing away of due process
right now this is it's it's indicative
of a society with both men and women who
don't know what a man is supposed to be
and I know now the feminists are gonna
listen this is just as much for women as
it is for men it is more important for
society right now to know what a man
needs to be and that means not just for
himself but for his woman and for his
family
patriarchy okay let's go with it because
I as a Christian I'm gonna be the one
standing before the Lord accountable for
my actions and my house whether you
don't believe in it but okay it proves
to be the case pragmatically even if you
look at sentencing not all men are
rapists let's start with that but all
good men hate rapists all good men all
good men that I know would fight to
their very last breath to prevent an
innocent woman from being raped even
hardened could deviate to you who get
hardened criminals and prisons thing
that's so crazy to me if you're a rapist
and you go to prison ironically you're
getting raped which we joke about in
this fine and I'm not saying that I'm
upset about that by it because of the
double standard I think it's funny but
it's just it's it's it's it's crazy to
me that people act as though we do not
tolerate rape every man I know hates
rapist even bad criminals armed robbers
arsonists hate rapists but you know what
the men you you want out there
castrating the rapists the men you cling
to when the wolves at the door they're
never the white knight modern male
feminists who travel in packs like the
wolves those men are cowards they don't
respect women they're just looking for
an inn and I saw this at the change my
mind with the guys walking in going oh I
think that this made my friend cry
you're just trying to get laid man you
didn't even have a point of view you
don't have any beliefs how am I supposed
to believe that you're gonna stand up
for anything you don't even stand for
anything yourself you came up to this
desk and you said well I'm really not
prepared shut up and go home and learn
to be
prepared because a man should be
prepared if you believe in anything this
isn't some false machismo bullcrap okay
I'm asking you
women genuinely what kind of a man do
you want when the wolves are at the door
if you're at a party you're
uncomfortable with some douchebags
around there drinking too much you feel
a little vulnerable who do you want
there with you
what kind of a man do you reach for it
doesn't have to be that extreme let's
say your supposed best friend at work
betrayed you toss her a lot on with the
rest of the gaggle in the office and
they got you to be fired from your job
okay I'm sure I think of some example
it's not as Extreme as rape but rape is
on the mind everything is rape every
bite these days laiá laiá ho and you
know it that's what's on the brain sorry
but okay let's just say you're in a
situation maybe many of you are in this
right now this is for the women out
there you have a friend but I hear this
story a lot I've heard it from I've had
it happen to me betray you you lost your
job you come home what kind of a man do
you want to reach for because that's
what matters
and to the men out there what kind of
man are you I understand this trials
evoke a lot of emotions right but I've
seen a lot of generalized negative talk
about all women I know how I sound when
I say this even though I think it's
important note that someone like Ford is
an exception not the rule so instead of
saying all women are crazy women suck
what kind of a man are you what kind of
a woman are you going to attract will it
be a Christi Ford can you say that you
are the man the woman who if you had to
pick right if you could pick the woman
you love are you the man in a roomful of
guys that she'd want by your side when
the wolves are at the door because that
comes with a track record that comes
with a track record that case that's not
a sit down and listen you made my friend
cry but I'm not really prepared for this
that's a track rest record a lifetime of
honesty integrity discipline no one just
rolls the dice on the squad leader and
if you're not that man you need to work
on yourself because the kind of woman
you want she's not going to want you so
I do get a little bit tired where I see
guys passing the buck going oh no I'm
afraid to date anyone because look women
are crazy no no maybe you need to look
at yourself - yeah things can happen you
can be totally in the right and they can
Brett Kavanaugh you allegedly for all I
think he's pretty probably did none of
it that's just my opinion at this point
but what about yourself are you the man
that the woman you would want would
choose
guess the point I'm trying to make is
that it's easy to make these assumptions
with some embargo Moo's lately that
either all women are crazy or all men
are scumbags and I know that's not true
you know that's not true
but it's time that really start working
on showing that women you need to have
higher expectations from your men period
which is not something that feminism has
taught feminism has let men off the hook
and many may have higher expectations of
yourself I also don't say you were raped
if you weren't raped
let me give an example of someone
because go back to it to anger when
people say anger is not a bad thing
there's righteous anger versus
douchebaggery Jesus knocked over the
temple a day would you call them tables
back then I don't know he's actually
basically Jesus was pissed Wow this is a
parent let's just say you're you believe
it's a parable let's let's just say
right that you don't you think you'd or
not sure if Jesus the man actually
exists okay the parable still believes
in a sinless man a perfect man who got
really pissed and threw over tables at
least caused property damage that's a
guy you want when the wolves are at the
door guy I have a lot of respect for
someone works in this show Johnny boy
I've told the story before I don't think
I've ever told it on air this is the
true story this is why he became my best
friend in high school and I'm great
enough to have him working on the show I
was talking with him right so you're me
and he's talking on the bus talking to
this is the front of the bus the camera
for this this is this is the back of the
bus he's talking with me I'm between the
camera and myself right now I hope I've
described us and we were talking
probably about jaws or something he
wanted he was obsessed with jaws and
there's a kid at the back of the bus
throwing pennies in there hitting him in
the back of it and he's talking he's
getting a little bit annoyed tells me
hold on a second I see him walk up to
the back of the bus this kid leave his
name was man says hey man could you
could you do me a favor could you stop
throwing out he's to have thrown pennies
guy says yeah what are you gonna do
could you stop throwing pennies please
walks back up to me sits down and share
this is me right this is the front
you're the camera you're the front of
the bus people listening on audio you
need to go watch this this is a visual
okay I'm creating a diagram just like
the score where they have the tunneling
so goes back talking to me about 30
seconds later
ding ding more pennies hitting his head
at this point my friend Johnny boy stops
looks back in other words the signal I
already asked you about this and the kid
who looks and gives him one of these I
think gave him the finger nothing else
was said we continued talking and the
pennies kept going for about two minutes
until all of a sudden we hear the kid
was getting off it was his stop by the
way they were in the same grade there
wasn't a size discrepancy as the kids
about to walk off the bus
looking over grinning my friend Johnny
boy is talking he goes hey hold on one
second stops me stands up looks at him
and hits him as hard as I've ever seen a
human being get hit and the guy stumbled
off the bus and about thirty seconds
later because the bus sure was going to
add got a cue his french-canadian he
kind of came to he goes yeah good offer
my stop see what happens well here's the
funny thing the next day guess what he
has to get back on that bus he did not a
word was spoken he didn't go out looking
for a fight
he wasn't a bully but there was nothing
wrong there that was righteous
indignation that was righteous anger and
guess what he's a friend of mine he's
the guy I would reach for as a buddy
when the wolves are at the door and
that's the kind of man you want to be to
your woman to your friends and if you're
a woman out there that's the kind of man
you want in your life and ironically
when we see this all the time even
though I believe you're strong
independent women like my wife is like
Johnny boy's wife is like my mother is
the only ones who are so weak that they
have to scream to be heard are the
liberal feminists are the people like
the Fords of the world are the people
like we sought to change my mind I think
so what you think this is an important
part of this conversation it's easy to
get pissed with rape and no rape and
she's crazy and this person's a [ __ ]
and this person is a jerk
I think it's important to take this
opportunity to say okay what are the
roles that we have in society as men and
as women and I think even more important
is not just what roles do we have as men
and as women but what are you looking
for in a man and a woman and today we
just talked about men maybe next week
we'll talk about women but I'll have to
get a consultant if you like this video
subscribe or click the notification bell
right next to the subscription but
because if scribing doesn't mean
anything anymore now according to the
YouTube gods and if you like the
late-night show you can watch it every
single day a full hour at large credit
calm slash mug Club subscribe
they're that way we aren't beholden to
the evil YouTube overlords and we don't
have to start playing video games with
mouths sound effects or children react